OLIVIER DE WECK: One of
the first assignments
that I ask students
to do in the class
is to write a team charter.
Now what is a team charter?
You can think of a team
charter like a manifesto.
It's essentially defining
the identity and the goals
that the team wants to pursue.
And in this kind of class, there
could be many different goals.
For example, as a team
you want to learn as much
as you can about the process of
systems engineering and design
and so forth.
Another charter could be
that you are very ambitious
and you want to win
the competition.
So you want to score
as high as you can.
And the ultimate goal is to be
as highly ranked as possible
in the competition.
Another goal could be just
to have fun, you know.
To just have a good
time, to learn,
but essentially to
really be together
in this learning
environment, to learn
and have fun at the same time.
And so the flavor of each team
is a little bit different.
And rather than just letting
it happen without much thought
or discussion, the purpose of
the team charter or project
charter is to encourage
these discussions early,
such that the team
is on the same page
as they proceed
into the project.